I've got a question given the quality of
electric cars what could possibly be the
excuse for buying a petrol and diesel
vehicle if you've got the money
[Music]
welcome to the climate show and this
week a first birthday a bit sad this
it's a year since I've had my electric
car in that time I've done 20 000 miles
and it's been almost completely Problem
free
I would accept there's a quite a high
upfront cost but aside from that I'm
perplexed why many people are still so
hostile to them I'm going to get on the
road and find out also on the show
as the North Sea faces record-breaking
heat we're on the Isle of May to hear
about the impact on marine life
and as it's Glastonbury this weekend
we'll show you how this turbine is
serving up Breezy burritos
thank you
so electric cars more of them are being
sold I love mine but plenty of people
still have their doubts
one advantage
you can plug it in at home
not many people have a petrol pump at
their house
so why are some people still holding
back on making the Switch I'll take you
through what it's like to own one and
ask those who remain unconvinced what it
would take
I've charged up at home for the trip as
I have off street parking like
two-thirds of households in this country
electricity bills have gone up a lot
recently but it's still cheaper than the
pump and much more so if you can
generate your own I am lucky enough to
have solar panels which makes the
electricity for my car both cheaper and
greener
but the cost of charging isn't the only
price hurdle
this car costs just over 40 000 Nearly
New
I accept that's Out Of Reach of many
electric vehicles cost on average just
over a third more than similarly specked
petrol or diesel ones
but if money is not an issue is it still
acceptable to buy a pricey new petrol
instead
I'm just arriving at the spot where
we've arranged to meet our owner of a
pricey gas guzzler somewhere he chose
it's a golf club
even if I couldn't see him I could hear
him coming
Jason is as fond of his car as I am mine
so
cost is clearly not a problem for you if
it came to buying an electric car
no no it's not no I think it's the right
car no it's definitely not so what is it
that puts you off
I think for me there's still a little
animotive
um boring
necessarily that it's boring it's a
different type it doesn't necessarily
you know I think part of it is noise it
always has been given that we are in
essence talking about well the fate of
human civilization in the face of
climate change is fun a good enough
reason to still be driving
well I'd ask the same question back
regarding any kind of adrenaline sports
or things like that for me this is a
little piece of heaven that I get to
enjoy
um you know I don't just say don't do a
significant amount of mileage so it's
not that I'm going through four to five
hundred pounds of fuel in a month you
know uh say so so for me I think this
was my little guilty pleasure it's nice
to have a look at what will be a museum
piece rather than sit on the future
absolutely
back on the road let's talk about range
anxiety another fear for drivers making
the switch this vehicle
will do either side of 250 miles
depending on the weather
and how fast you drive so put simply if
it was very cold in your Motorway
driving you might get down to nearer 200
miles range if it was weather like this
and you're on a roads I've had 300 out
of it
given the need for safety and brakes
this seems very acceptable after all in
2021 61 of all car Journeys were less
than five miles
flipping over can also shrink our carbon
footprint the 20 000 miles I've done in
this car in a year would have resulted
in four tons of CO2 being emitted and
while construction emissions are higher
than for traditional cars that's more
than made up for by zero emission
driving
we're in London now and one of the
advantages of electric cars is you don't
have to pay the congestion charge
also one of the ways in which electric
car drivers could rightly be accused of
being a bit smug
I'm here to visit the new car Awards to
ask about the prevailing mood in the
industry over EVS still a buzz all gone
flat given the quality of electric cars
now is it really a moral for wealthy
people to buy internal combustion engine
cars
I think the short answer to that
question is no it's not amoral I mean
wow who thought we'd be talking about
morality when it came to cars but
electric means we're kind of at that
point right
um I don't think it is a moral for other
people to buy ice cars I think that we
have an issue which is that electric
cars are really expensive and
manufacturers can't bring the prices
down anymore because there's no profit
margins in them so your point is that
electric cars are currently subsidized
by I don't know cars like this big big
internal combustion engine cars that
that cost they make more margin on them
they do and so I think at the moment
while we're still trying to make that
transition to mass adoption of electric
cars we need those wealthy buyers to
come forward and help fund that help
fund the research there's still a lot of
research to be doing in making batteries
better we need that input when it comes
to these other things you know cost of
running range anxiety charging
infrastructure where do you think we are
with that I mean do you think any of
those give a good reason for not giving
an electric car at the moment the public
charging Network isn't where it needs to
be we know that there are about 40 000
charges on the roads we need way more
than that before we reach 2030. that is
a big concern it's probably a very real
one but a lot more of these concerns
actually are perception versus reality
so people think that the batteries are
going to degrade people think that the
range isn't going to be enough and
actually if you speak to EV owners after
a period of ownership they haven't found
many of those worries have been realized
I need to charge up myself before the
drive back home are those fears
well-founded so I found a charger and it
is delivering the electricity
successfully but there can be some
irritations with these things one thing
it's very difficult to see how much
you'll be paying for the electricity and
that's completely different from most
garages where the petrol and diesel
prices are clearly displayed another
thing it can with some charges be
difficult to get to pay you need to have
a special card or you need to pre-load
an app sometimes the sort of stuff
computer says no to be fair this has
worked pretty well today and then the
speed of charge can vary
I have to open my door just to get it to
register this says it's charging at 68
69 kilowatts that's pretty quick it will
take 12 minutes to get to 80 of my
battery
that's not bad
just time to sneak in some cheeky Road
food
refueled it's time to go home whether
you're a true EV convert or still on the
fence the window for choice is rapidly
closing with a ban on new petrol and
diesel cars just six and a half years
away there's only one direction of
travel
with that deadline looming though it's
not just about public acceptance it's
also about the materials to make the
vehicles and all the other electronics
which is expanding in our world to talk
about that I'm joined by Sky's economics
editor Ed Conway who knows all about
this and has brought some props love a
prop let's just start with the cars and
obviously lithium is the one that people
talk about how much where does it come
from where are we with that lithium
which we have here it comes out of the
ground uh in various places that stuff
is actually from the UK so that's from
Cornwall okay it's it's a place called
British lithium it's lithium carbonates
that's why it's the kind of you know
it's it's so we can extract it grains of
it we can extract it here and the big
plans are fit to do that but the vast
majority of it comes from either Chile
or Australia and we are mining more and
more of it
um the issue is like we've only just
started working out how to do it like
you know all of the other kind of
materials that that we tend to use we've
got a long history hundreds of years
thousands of years in some case of
mining them well lithium we just don't
really you know no we still haven't got
the full Knack of so getting out of the
ground is still a bit of a challenge
there's a lot of talk about its
environmental impact and just spoiling
the places where it's extracted does it
kind of have to be like that do you
think or is that just because we're in
the early stages well it's just it's
just hard to think of anything that we
get out of the ground without having
some sort of an environmental impact and
it's all it's all about the balance you
know it's about a gray area it's about
offsetting the fact that you know we are
we have a massive carbon emitter at the
moment if we're trying to do something
about that and we know to a much greater
extent what the impact of that is for
climate change and on my flip side yes
you are having to move a lot of Earth
potentially to get a lot of this lithium
to some extent you're burning carbon as
well to some extent you're going into
quite pristine ecosystems particularly
in Chile where you've got places like
the salad Atacama where there's Flamingo
populations where no one's sure what's
happening to the ecosystem when you pull
out all of the Brine and turn it into
this stuff so there are you know there
are going to be compromised I mean that
that is the interesting thing to my mind
we shouldn't be blind to the fact that
there are compromises the point though
is to say that the good offsets the bad
you know the good of reducing carbon
emissions reducing all of the emissions
that come out of a petrol engine car are
kind of offsetting all of those damages
that we might be doing and it's also not
as if carbon emissions is the only bad
that comes from oil and gas I mean you
know you look at the areas of the world
that have been despoiled by extracting
this stuff yeah um I mean just
thousands millions of Acres
extraordinary just extraordinary and uh
and we're still doing it and that's
that's the kind of slightly important
thing to bear in mind you know we think
we are weaning ourselves off this no
we're just kind of slowing the race at
which we're getting out of the ground to
some extent and we're still enormously
reliant on it not just to go into car
engines although that is you know the
biggest chunk of Reliance on crude oil
but it's also it's making products it's
Plastics and there's a whole you know
another kind of set of questions about
what kind of damage we're doing food
Plastics talk to me about some of these
other minerals well so I mean okay
talking about the energy transition
we're going to need a lot of copper we
can actually copper in a way even more
important than lithium because you need
copper not just for things like electric
cars and for uh for for the kind of
Contraptions we're using but for the
grids you know we're going to have
massively more Reliance on electricity
on power uh when it when we've got all
those wind turbines but to have those
wind turbines you need big Tech cables
with copper going through them you need
lots of copper Motors uh wires that was
incredibly thick incredibly thick cables
when you when you see them and so we
need lots more of this stuff this is
called pyrite it's a copper ore that
also comes from Chile has the world's
biggest reserves in Copper and of
lithium and the issue here is that we
need to basically double the amount of
copper we're getting out of the ground
if we are going to fulfill all of those
promises we've made you've written a
book about this uh give me the title
well it's called material world and it's
just it's trying to tell the the world's
story it's not it's partly about Net
Zero but it's partly about a bit of our
history it's partly about the fact that
we are reliant on these materials so
obviously lithium we mentioned crude oil
copper that's Iron by the way so you
know steel is is absolutely critical for
the survival of the world and indeed for
our development that stuff's from Brazil
salt you know we kind of think that salt
is just this kind of boring condiment
you sprinkle on your chips and of course
it is and it's great and I love salt but
we use it for chemicals and they are
incredibly important you know you've got
salt that goes into chlorine purifying
our drinking water without you know pure
drinking water without salt we're in big
trouble and then you can't really make
stuff without salt because it provides
these chemicals like caustic soda which
enable you to take things like lithium
and turn it into these powders that we
can actually use and then finally sand
you know silicon chips concrete all of
those things
um glass for that matter these are the
kind of materials that we built
civilization on and so it's just you
know it's a story about all of that
stuff with all these things you're
talking about you know greater
exploitation
um is there a feeling that we can do
this in in a better way is there a move
to try and shrink the environmental
impact within the industry I think you
know just need to be honest there are no
silver bullets here it's going to be
potentially a bit dirtier than we think
it is going to be to get to Net Zero but
that shouldn't stop us from wanting to
do it we should just be open-eyed about
it and understand the importance of
these materials in the stuff that we're
touching every day because it all
basically begins with this stuff Ed
Conway thank you so much we're off to a
break now when we come back we'll be
going to Glastonbury amongst other
places where we'll be seeing how a wind
turbine is helping to make a sustainable
samosas
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the show and you find me
on the Isle of May which is in the North
Sea just off the east coast of Scotland
and I'm here because we're filming
something for next week all about
puffins and robots well actually
artificial and intelligence but it's
really relevant this place to something
that's happening right now and that is
what they're calling a category four
extreme ocean Heat Wave the waters
around the UK particularly here in the
North Sea and on the west coast of
Ireland have seen a temperature rise
near the surface of four to five degrees
and that can really harm wildlife and
I'm going to have a talk about this
right now with the guy who is the warden
for this place and has been here for
nine years so he's really able to see
the trends and changes in the waters
around here
what is bad you know the cold water the
upwellings bringing the Plankton and
then the sand eels to the surface for
all these seabirds to be feeding on and
of course the temperatures of a sea at
this moment in time but here we are in
mid-june we don't normally see these
temperatures until about mid-september
so already three months three and a half
months ahead of where we should be
that's not good these Birds can't adapt
that quickly
also in the news this week the
government has come under Fire for
removing a ban on opening new coal mines
from the energy bill currently going
through Parliament
that's despite coal use in the UK
powermix being at record lows and facing
a complete ban next year the government
says it wants to ensure security of
supply for Industries like steel cement
and Heritage Steam
Church of England has announced that
it's divesting from Seven big oil and
gas companies including shell BP Exxon
and total after concluding that none of
them were aligned with the Paris
agreement to limit warming shell itself
Drew criticism last week for pledging to
further grow its gas business and not
cut oil output in February BP also
backtracked on plans to cut oil and gas
production by 40 this decade last year
these companies saw rapid profits they
really had the chance to to transition
they had the opportunity to really
invest in the transition and show that
they meant the targets that they had set
and that we've seen engagement we wanted
to bring them on board we thought it
would be better if they were on board
but after the last year we just we've
lost faith in them and we just don't
think that they're serious
your research has shown that using a gas
hob can flood your home with levels of
the cancer causing chemical Benzene to
levels worse than second-hand smoke or
even for areas neighboring oil and gas
facilities
the researchers from Stanford University
in California found that high levels
remain in the home for up to six hours
after the hob was used
it is Glastonbury this weekend and
caring for the environment has always
been Central to the festival's ethos
since its Beginnings in 1970. this year
is no different and skies Jason Manta
Ray has got the tough beat of finding
out all about it
thanks Tom uh hello and welcome to
Glastonbury Festival the sun is out and
I'm enjoying a lovely Falafel now the
reason I'm eating that is because stores
like this one at least in part are
powered by this turbine here now it's
from octopus energy and it's not just a
sign of sustainability they say it's a
show how quickly it can be done it was a
month from ordering to installation now
two people who can talk a little bit
more about how this works and what it
does is the lovely Alexia and Luke from
Glastonbury
um do you want to tell us first of all
uh how much energy is this actually
providing so I went to Albin that we've
installed this year is a 45 kilowatt
wind turbine and that can produce
roughly around 300 kilowatt hours a day
with the wind that we have coming out
the valley and that's equivalent to the
same energy use as around 30 homes or
300 fridges for one day it's a
phenomenal amount of energy but it's not
the only source of energy that you're
coming in here it seems to be like a
combination of different approaches
you're taking yeah a sustainability has
always been at the heart of Glastonbury
Festival our greenfields have always run
on solar and wind power since their
Inception in the 1980s and our dream has
always been to implement that across the
site and this year we're absolutely
thrilled to be able to power the
festival needs through fossil fuel free
means there's over 200 000 people that
are coming to a rural area to a farm to
eat to consume to drink to go to the
bathroom there is an impact there though
well when you bring 200 000 people to a
field in rural Somerset they're always
going to have challenges but we're quite
well set up for it now and and when
they're here they use less water than
they would at home because they're not
showering as much and all their waste is
hand hand shifted hand sifted to our at
our own recycling center on site so we
can avoid sending any waste to landfill
so we're really pleased to be able to
have that infrastructure in place I'm
very finely and very briefly how long
until you guys have like a zero impact
whatsoever everything we've been doing
at the festival for not only the last
couple years last 50 years is an
evolution every year we look at what
have we done what can we do a little bit
better and I think our ambition is to
take our learnings from this year do a
little bit more next you know so I don't
want to put a time frame on it but we'll
get there you know we've already gone
fossil fuel free and I think it's going
to happen you know in the near future
now the waters around me here in the
Firth of fourth used to have huge oyster
beds some of which were the size of the
nearby City of Edinburgh but in a
familiar story they were all fished out
now a project going on in the Dornoch
Firth a little further north from here
shows the potential of reintroductions
not only for the oysters themselves but
for wider nature
the reason that wishes do enhance
biodiversity is due to the structure
they provide so we've got live oyster
shells we've got dead oyster shells and
the Matrix of them combined creates all
these little cracks and nooks and
crannies that are homes for other
animals
foreign
[Music]
we put some oysters back into the system
to show that they could still grow and
survive and then we've been optimizing
that process of restoration so basically
you know working out how to re-establish
the habitat type how to get the oysters
in there and building up those
populations over time
foreign
[Music]
there's a couple of next conservation
orders that restrict the removal of
shellfish from the door knock first so
there's loads of bird life wading Birds
Ducks geese and there's lots of seals
that fall out on the sandbanks there's
fish that migrate up the river through
the Estuary there's all sorts of sponges
and and shellfish on the seabed so it's
really quite Ridge already but there's
this Missing Link the oysters that
haven't been there for over 100 years
[Music]
and we always hope that other
restoration initiatives will take our
example and I think in terms of Industry
Partners the fact that we could have
such a clear return
[Music]
um as you know an output or consequence
of restoration it makes the whole idea
that a lot more attractive to um to
Industry partners and to other
conservation agencies
[Music]
now before we go just a reminder that
you can catch up on all your environment
and climate news on the Sky News website
an app or by scanning the QR code that's
on your screen right now next week we'll
be here or actually a little offshore
looking at how the very latest tech
artificial intelligence could help
puffins
see you then
[Music]